merci monsieur le président nous
arrivons donc comme vous viens de vous
le dire lui qu'au terme de cette
première journée et je voudrais comme
vice-présidente des républicains et
intérimaires un instant vous remercier
de votre participation active crois que
nous sommes écoutés nous nous sommes
exprimés et nous avons co produit nous
somems retrouvez moi complètement dans
la ligne qui vient d'être décrite à
l'instant par francis de la fédération
du nord qui nous a dit qu'il était
libéral social et européen
je me retrouve parfaitement demain après
les interventions de nos dirigeants et
le discours de notre président nicolas
sarkozy nous rentrerons chez nous avec
une feuille de route et je le pense avec
une énergie décuplée
si vous me le permettez je voudrais vous
délivrer trois messages
le premier ne laissait pas caricaturer
le bilan du mandat d'avant nicolas
sarkozy est un président françois fillon
premier ministre les ministres
ab - le souci du casting que celui de
l'efficacité réelle
sachez rappelé pêle-mêle les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées la réforme
des retraites les droits de succession
le soutien à l'accession à la propriété
le service minimum dans les transports
la réforme des universités la loi qui
crée le conseiller territorial la liste
est longue très longue
sans oublier la crise financière sans
précédent qu'il a fallu gérer et prendre
à bras le corps
c'était du temps où la france comptait
en europe
chers collègues députés européens et
faisait preuve d'un véritable
volontarisme politique
ce temps et l as révolue j'en veux pour
preuve ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
l'agriculture j'accuse
j'accuse absences coupables du président
hollande
gouvernement qui rechignent à les
défendre les éleveurs à bruxelles
deuxième message ne laissait pas dire
que l'opposition des républicains au
parlement est une opposition
systématique
c'est faux nous sommes quasiment 200
députés est quasiment 100 sénateurs et
nous travaillons nous auditionnons nous
faisons des propositions
s'il ya bien une opposition systématique
c'est celle du gouvernement et de la
majorité de gauche ou ce qu'il en reste
à nos propositions
alors ne vous laissez pas bercer par les
discours du premier ministre qui en
appelle hypocritement à l'unité
nationale
sachez que c'est bien son gouvernement
qui refuse le débat et les solutions
justes parce qu'elles viennent de nous
j'en veux pour preuve une nouvelle fois
ce qui se passe avec l'agriculture
pardonnez moi mais je ne décolère pas
depuis que j'ai compris que la majorité
socialiste avec baisser les bras et ne
se battait plus ou si mal les sénateur
dépose discute évoque une proposition de
loin à la quasi-unanimité destiné à
redonner de la compétitivité aux
agriculteurs qui sont avant tout des
entrepreneurs
le groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale l'inscrit dans une
niche parlementaire
le groupe socialistes déposent une
motion de rejet coupant court à tout
débat troisième message soyez fiers
soyez fiers d'être membre de notre
famille politique
vous avez pu le constater tout au long
de la journée nous partageons des
valeurs communes
nous élaborons un projet avec les
français nous comptons d'immenses
talents et de fort tempérament dans
n'auront certes il y entre nous les
nuances mais ce qui nous rassemble est
bien plus fort que ce qui pourrait nous
diviser nous disposons de toutes les
ressources nécessaires pour aller à la
rencontre de nos concitoyens pour
susciter l'adhésion pour donner une
autre image de la vie politique
nous sommes ceux qui
ils ont et qui faisant un exemple
toujours empreint à ce thème qui m'est
si chère car il est le pilier de
l'économie bretonne et que mon combat
c'est l'emploi l'agriculture
il y a dix jours nous avons consacré
notre réunion de travail au siège des
républicains à l'agriculture et à la
ruralité travail de fond témoignages
vivants ont permis d'élaborer un
document de constat et de propositions
concrètes cher eric une matière qui le
demandent qu'à vivre désormais dans nos
fédérations ce qui a été fait sur
l'agriculture existe sur l'immigration
sur le code du travail sur la sécurité
est comme nous vous l'avons dit nous
allons continuer sur tous les thèmes qui
intéressent et préoccupent les français
saisissez vous de tous ces outils et
déployer les dans vos territoires en
conclusion je laisse à votre méditation
cet enseignement d'un poète breton qui
s'appelle eugène guillevic plus de nous
on est enracinée plus on est universel
si nos racines
c'est bien cette devise de la république
française liberté égalité fraternité
nous avons alors à vocation à rester
unis et à rassembler bien au-delà de
notre famille politique
bonne soirée et à demain